في مصر موضوع شائك يتعلق بقضايا النسب
اثره مجددا الدكتور علي جمعه عضو هيئه
كبار العلماء بالازهر جمعه شدد على ان
تحليل الدي ان ايه ليس دليلا واجبا لاثبات
النسب مؤكدا على الالتزام بقاعده الولد
للفراش طبعا هو موضوع محل جدل دائم بين
مؤيد ومعارض سواء من رجال دين او حتى من
قانونيين اذ اجازت دار الافتاء اثبات
النسب بالبصمه الوراثيه في حاله تنازع على
مجهول النسب او الاشتباه في المواليد
واطفال الانابيب
[موسيقى]
يعني هل هي حاله واحده مختصه بما ذكره ام
هي حاله عامه على كل الاسر يجب ان لا ناخذ
حفاظا على هذه الاسره حتى لو كان هناك
اختلاف بين الزوج والزوجه او طعن من قبل
احد الاقارب او غيره بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم قال الله تعالى ذلك ومن يعظم شعائر
الله فانها من تقوى القلوب بطبيعه الحال
في باب اثبات النسب في الفقه الاسلامي
عندنا نصان نص قراني ونص نبوي النص
القراني قال الله تعالى في سوره الاحزاب
ادعوهم لابائهم فان لم تعلموا اباءهم
فاخوانكم في الدين ومواليكم والنص النبوي
قال النبي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
الولد للفراش يعني للزوجيه الصحيحه
احنا لا نرفض تحليل dna لكن هو قرينه وليس
دليلا فقهيا شرعيا قطعيا لاثبات النسب لان
من المستحيل شرعا ان تلغى ايه قرانيه او
يلغى حديث نبوي او نقول ان العلم الحديث
قال يعني مثلا في علاقات محرمه اللي هي
علاقات الزنا هل ياتي دي ان ايه ليلحق او
يثبت نسب من الناحيه الفقهيه الش رعيه لا
اثبات النسب انما بالزواج
باركانه وشروطه اسال الدكتور عادل
في الحقيقه
يعني الناحيه العلميه هل الدي ان اي يعتبر
دليل قاطع لا شك ولا ريب فيه في اثبات
النسب عم بحكي علميا تمام يا فندم يعتبر
تحليل تقنيه
دليل كامل بنسبه 100% على اثبات
البنوه
لما انها تحمل بدرجه دقيقه جدا تصل الى
100% في اثبات النسب او الانساب بالنسبه
للاطفال وهي الحقيقه
تقنيه غير مكلفه
والحقيقه التقنيه دي برده عايزه اخش في
حته تانيه انها بتكون رضع للزوج او للزوجه
او الراجل او المراه اللي بترتكب فاحشه
وعارفه ان ما فيش تحليل هيثبت ارتكابها
للفاحشه دي سواء الرجل او الست وبالتالي
لما انا اعرف ان في تحليل هيثبت اني الطفل
ده
ابني او مش ابني اعتقد بالنسبه لي او
بالنسبه
للزوجه او للمراه هتكون راضع لها وده
يحافظ كمان على الاسره
[موسيقى]